[Applaudissements]
oeuvres abstraites résolument moderne
artistes entre hayden prix demandé entre
75 mille et un demi million de dollars
la toile en quelques mots on aura tout
dit de la plus récente controverse dont
fait l'objet la famille byden la
question à 1000 $ ou plutôt à 500 mille
dollars
les oeuvres du fils du président ancien
le billet est devenu peintre va-t-elle
vraiment autant d'argent
[Musique]
ces choses là n'arrivent tout simplement
pas répond sans hésiter cette galeriste
une turbine commence à peine à peindre
picasso lui même n'avait pas touché
autant pour ses premiers tableaux
son avis est largement partagé dans les
blogs les journaux et les médias sociaux
personnes du milieu des arts nous semble
croire un instant comme cobayes donne
pourrait exiger autant d'argent s'il
n'était le fils du président ils misent
sur le nom de son père pour prendre ces
tableaux tranche-t-elle c'est pitoyable
mais qu'à cela ne tienne une exposition
est déjà prévue à l'automne dans des
galeries de los angeles et de new york
une bien mauvaise idée estime cet ancien
conseiller en éthique de la maison
blanche selon qui le président devrait
inciter son fils à attendre
la maison blanche croit pourtant avoir
trouvé une solution a pour éviter tout
conflit d'intérêts le nom des acheteurs
et les montants payés seront gardés
entièrement secret explique sa
porte-parole
hunter byden ne sera pas lui-même
combien d'argent il fera bref tout le
contraire de la transparence déplore
cette éthiciens s'est passé
la migration byden et bien naïve dit il
gère tout finit par se savoir
dans le petit monde de l'art c'est la
deuxième fois en quelques mois que les
agissements de peinture byden met son
père dans l'embarras pendant des années
il a touché des dizaines de milliers de
dollars par mois pour siéger au conseil
d'administration d'une obscure compagnie
gazière ukrainienne
une affaire dont s'est servi d'un autre
forme pour attaquer son adversaire
durant la dernière campagne
présidentielle
issus de la vallée radio-canada
washington